But not everything is a big data problem. There are lots
of cases where you can use a traditional system to store, manage
and process your data. So the first thing you need to
decide, is do you really have big data? To make that call,
we need some sort of definition of what big data means.
Which of these would you consider to be big data? You won't
be graded on this. Just give it your best guess. Would
you consider the order details for purchases at a single store to
be big data. Or all orders across
hundreds of stores nationwide. Say, an individual's
stock portfolio. Or all stock transactions for
the New York Stock Exchange for a year.